la série tu fais des trucs toiture 20
jours vient enfin dîner ont quatre comme
ça on se marre il faut
il faut trouver à manger c'est ça mieux
c'est ça que je veux mon aventure c'est
pas mal amazon c'est super parce que la
nuit tu as donc des mcdo
il ya une vérité quand même on n'arrive
pas avec les crocodiles ça se passe bien
dans ses mains mais tu es ce que tu as
déjà comme un tout et déjà reste ils
sont mangés ajoie ce qu'un jour tu sais
quoi deux semaines sans manger ça peut
arriver mais il faut boire c'est sûr il
faut beaucoup trop boire un pays qui
était déjà arrivé de papou réussir à
boire et que voilà tu dises il faut que
je bois mon pipi ses côtés
contre pas vraiment on peut pas vraiment
boire notre pipi c'est une connerie il
faut quand on boit en litres de pépi il
faut mehdi lido avec comme ça tu peux tu
prêt à allonger encore quand on tombe
parfois
[Rires]
incroyable
la nature est tellement bien fait que en
fait il fournit tout la nature c'est
super c'est en fait je bouquine qui
connaît pas et c'est ça et dans la
jungle tout ce que le sang je mange donc
plus que manger oui et puis c'est sûr
qu'avec un suspect un bouquin boison
manges tu peux manger comme s'ils
savaient pays comme son pote avec un
animal genre à saint-georges qui est en
train de muer
et toi tu t'es rendu compte qu'en fait
en fait où on a tous la toile et wim
away c'est sûr je te jure si tu sais pas
quoi manger et à sange qui a honte dont
les arguments juifs aux hivers suivants
il faut tu peux monter tu peux manger
des feuilles vertes d'accord il est
certain mais on mange rien tu as tu un
peu embêté mais là tu peux toujours
monté pour manger l'yssingelais
attrapé tu peux le faire
manger un truc de fou mais écoutez un
peu pourri c'est vrai ces défauts pourri
dans quoi quand chuté pendant deux ans
il faut changer dit qu'ils se battre
entre eux ah oui j'y suis tu et puis
après qui arrive sur les plages oui bien
fait les recteurs ça pourri pendant
pendant l'été et puis après les inuits
et les eskimos imanche à oued et fassent
qu'un c'est
très très vieux faux fromages
et attaques à manger ça pique la langue
c'est vrai il a mangé du phoque pourri
mais bon en fait je veux dire quand tu
manques duboc je sais pas s'il est pour
ou par
mail à certains que ça et tu l'as fait
griller ou bien tu la manges et non non
tu veux il n'y a pas de bois ouais ça
veut dire que tu peux pas le faire
griller tu la manges comme une vie de
merde
[Rires]
merci
roger glover avec lui je la donne dans
le cinéma s il a une vie doigté fois
déjà resté seul genre pendant plein de
temps comme c'est ce que tu as tu eu
peur
la peur devient ma maison en fait c'est
ce rapport tu fais rien excitant
exactement et que moi tu peux pas rester
totalement dans ce rapport a pas peur
près ils aiment avoir peur il le dit
dans le documentaire fut exactement
n'empêche que sa vraie et voilà et bing
sans ressort
[Applaudissements]
il ya 99% de chances qu'il termine pas
là n'est
pas vraiment c'est un mec que j'aime
vous le savez mike horn que j'admire
énormément tu as toi pour ton
documentaire mike horn survivre à
l'impossible dans le premier épisode 87
jours dont l'enfer du pôle nord sera
diffusée demain à 21h05 chez nos amis de
rmc des couvertures vient dans cet
épisode sur la terrible aventure que tu
as vécu au pôle nord on lui dise aux
futurs appels on a eu très très peur
pour toi mike vraiment on en avait parlé
d'ailleurs et que ta fille ici qui était
venu nous voir et c'est vrai que j'avais
j'étais en angoisse pour toi je j'ai
besoin d'avoir des nouvelles on était
nul très peur pour toi mais c'est sûr
que quand tu pousses des limites de
faire quelque chose qui n'a jamais été
fait par avance et c'est là où tu partes
on connu mais si tu as peur de mourir il
faut pas y aller c'est ça il faut avoir
cette envie de gagner et en colombie de
gagner devient plus plus fort que la
peur de perdre c'est là où tu as et ses
boutons tout acabit je vais y arriver je
sais que quand je perds tu perds ma vie
mais je veux tout faire pour la garder
pour sur veste est vivant et puis après
ou 87 jours tu arrives l'autre côté et
puis tu peux pas partir parce qu'à dix
bateaux est prise dans la gaspillent
sanitas faire écraser 130 jours plus
tard tu es toujours là et puis tu te
bats ta vie c'est une fois que tu sortes
dit
wahou ses efforts c'est très mauvais
[Applaudissements]